yes I have begun several projects which
were never completed not necessarily
because they failed but because I got
interested in other things and some of
them were looking quite promising I mean
for example I began a project on the
song of crickets this is when I was
still working in a department of animal
behavior crickets sing by vibrating
their wings against each other and
different species of crickets have a
different pattern of song which they
control by the by the movement of the
wings and I was working on a South
Pacific
crickets not in the South Pacific I had
a colony of them in Oxford this
particular cricket Tilia Gorillaz
oceanic --is has a rather complicated
song it says that just goes on and on
and on and I wanted to know how
important the details of that song were
did it really have to have that
particular pattern and if the answer was
probably yes because it was unique to
that species related species have a
different kind of song for example tea
liberal Oscar murders a related species
said and presumably the difference
between those two crickets was
significant what I did was to write a
computer program to make a computer sing
like a cricket and in which you could
easily program in using a simple sort of
language which I devised for for making
any cricket song you like so I was able
to program quickly the song of T Lea
Willis Oceania cos T liberal Oscar modus
there is species of gorillas and so on
and then I devised a method for
measuring the attractiveness of these
songs and it was it was a very light
seesaw made of sort of balsa wood very
very light balsa wood and at each end of
the seesaw was a loudspeaker which could
be made to play artificial cricket song
when the you put a cricket inside the
seesaw
as the cricket walked along the seesaw
towards the song the seesaw tilted and
made an electrical contact which was
counted as one approach to that
loudspeaker at that point already or
shortly afterwards the computer would
change to making the song come out of
the other lot loudspeaker whereupon the
cricket would turn around and walk the
other way and then the seesaw were tilt
the other way so the number of tilts of
the seesaw was a measure of the
attractiveness of the song so I had it
all set up to measure the rival
attractiveness of different kinds of
song but then I can't remember what
happened and I switched to some other
piece of piece of research so that piece
of research was never actually done but
the apparatus that I developed and the
and the computer program as I wrote to
sing like a cricket was all working now
it's lost forever because it was done on
now outdated computers you can't get
that kind of computer anymore and so
that's that's gone